(scratching)
(buzzer)
- Look, I hate to sound like
a click baity Jezebel article,
but this is just
seasonal sexual assault.
You shouldn't be
able to plant one
on an unsuspecting friend
wearing a particularly
perky sweater,
because the holidays.
A piece of plant doesn't
make someone your ho, ho, ho.
(scratching)
(buzzer)
A Charlie Brown Christmas
is horribly depressing.
Bad animation.
Obnoxious real kid voices,
and a contemporary
jazz soundtrack
that goes well with a nice
mix of eggnog and Drano.
It is best watched
when you're alone,
and you know things won't
get better anytime soon.
And at the end, the kid
who clings to his blanket
starts yapping about Jesus.
It's a Christmas special.
I don't wanna hear about Jesus.
The greatest
Christmas special is
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
Drunk ass bro
lives, misfit toys,
a dentist elf that looks
like Ellen DeGeneres.
And Yukon Cornelius,
a broddy explorer
that also looks like
every Brooklyn drummer,
or just me without glasses
after CrossFit lessons.
(scratching)
(buzzer)
Mariah Carey has three
things going for her
that make her better
than Whitney Houston.
One, that cool whistley thing
she does with her voice.
Two, the ability to
just revive a bath.
And three, the fact that
she's the only person
to make a new Christmas song
that's an instant classic
in All I Want for
Christmas is You.
Michael Bublé, Adam
Levine, Josh Grobin,
and every other
singer you don't get,
but your mom wants to fuck,
have attempted new Christmas
classics and failed.
Many people can try-a, yet
no one's done it but Mariah.
And no I'm not sure if
I should be more ashamed
that that rhymed,
or the bathtub joke.
(buzzer)